bah le top aussi c'était top gear sur
rmc découvert 699 mille téléspectateurs
donc presque 700 bin là on va pas se
mentir et dans l'émission d'hier il y
avait michel cymes et lors de son tour
circuit est ce qu'il a été plus rapide
que benjamin castaldi ou pas vous
l'aviez fait la semaine d'avant mais
vous avez été vous est ce que michel
cymès a été meilleur que vous je ne sais
pas mais on va d'abord concentrer dès le
départ un démarrage plus que cohérent
tu es heureux
non
concentré
t-shirt chasse les pneus étaient un peu
lisse [ __ ] la dalle est ce que tu as
vu révision
la ligne d'arrivée une minutes 25
secondes et 61 centièmes
oui
alors en bagarre vous n'avez même pas de
compte elle a conduit hier à douala
fait pas rêver de ça si c'est oui mais
castaldi quand même ils nous bassinent
sans cesse avec sa narration des
voitures est battu par un médecin pour
la peur freemont d'engenio domaine toul
mais nuls
imaginez quand t'es pas une passion
illégaux mais bon et l'a jamais dit il a
dit qu'il était bon en voiture mais en
passager la ville avec la voulait
d'abord répondre après pardon c'est long
mais ils ne connaissent rien pardon mais
les conditions météo n'avaient rien à
voir rien
eh bien ça change beaucoup par rapport à
ce qu'on fait chez combien de boulot en
soirée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
sur pas d'excusés ni excuse tout le
temps mais là c'était très drôle pour
une fois on ira dîner formidable moyen
louette
non mais c'est vrai nom et voilà le
cirque connaître comme une bonne base
d'eau mais c'est évidemment pas
justement d'en écouter la fin de cette
année vous dis que c'est pas drôle non
mais parce qu'elle est un bond à l'art
musulman
benjamin oui non rien c'est dans cette
déroute
oui centièmes ou 10e c'est pas grand
chose mais non c'est pas énorme c'est
pas énorme
bon c'est pas très beau père n'est pas
grave c'est pas vous savez j'ai
l'habitude de quoi de perdre êtes un
gagnant et un winner et benjamin je vous
le dis vous allez reprendre cette
voiture salaires aussi grave
c'est pas grave moi vous êtes le
meilleur c'est pas grave je n'ai besoin
que deux que de rien si tu feras ce qui
resterait ça dans les babas du prochain
merci la n'y a ni ça vous fait de la
peine qu'il ait perdu au bras un petit
peu quand même
ludivine fait que occupy bien sûr à me
ce qui n'est pas bien mon peine d'amour
balla et je vous le dis en ce moment je
le trouve de plus beau que michael se
serait excusé moi je viens vous trouvez
ça suffit maintenant arrêter m'attendais
pas non non rien assurément rien c'est
ça m'a dit moi aussi je lèche bien oui
c'est ça ma brave on ira bien elle se
lâche à n'en pas douter voilà je gère
bien j'aime bien remettre mon ami en
selle et opaque ou théodore secours
n'est pas